you just found yourself the tales of mr.
collector a limited-edition story
collection from doctor one detainment hi
there my name is mr. money nowhere I
just needed something to talk to seeing
is it's just you and me on the bus
might as well be you I talked to the
driver but there's a sign right there
saying not to take do not disturb the
driver I wouldn't do that saying inside
the bus might crash I'd have to walk all
the way if I walk and rain like this let
me tell you it's freezing so I'm just
gonna sit here and talk to you you oh
come on
don't move I'm just being friendly here
take this
see we're we're pals now right yes it's
a diamond yes it's real you see pal I
know how friendship works hear me what's
your name anyway
well hello Dave it's nice to meet a
smart fellow like yourself I usually
hang around with this group Oh you would
not believe they didn't understand how
friendship works no they did not
not like you Dave I gave them dollars
and dimes and [ __ ] diamonds and all
they did is call me a snob me can you
believe that Dave how about the diamond
you're a good friend and you look like
you could use it
seriously though me a snob it's not easy
to get all this cash
believe me picking out the bills is fine
they come out easy even coins are no big
deal
but with diamonds it's not so easy you
could choke on diamonds I have a few
times let me tell you good thing was a
sweetie was there though I would have
been a goner
she was always very kind
this is sweetie even if she just pitied
me just [ __ ] pity me
stop [ __ ] moving Dave no don't go
okay look have another diamond please
I'm sorry for shouting I didn't mean to
once we've gotten that from mr.
read-only shouting give me a headache
I don't mind say what's that well Dave
it's a very good question I don't
[ __ ] know why I can puke money so
shut the [ __ ] up
sorry diamond sorry I'll tell you what I
do know because friends share secrets
we're friends right Dave I have to know
what kind of money I want to puke I
couldn't just spit up some yen or
something for you right now because I've
never been to Asia and I don't know what
yen looks like ever been to Asia suppose
not
flights are kind of expensive so enough
about me
where you headed me I'm headed for well
I don't really know
while I'm getting there before those
little shits I know that they said it
wasn't a race but let me tell you Dave
it's always a race have a diamond
[Music]